こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
はい
誕生日を迎えて24歳になりました。
えっと皆さま本当にありがとうございました！
誕生日の日はですね
あの後カラオケに行って
寝て、起きて、モンハンして、スプラトゥーンして、遊戯王して、
終わりました！
後、編集もね！
というですね、あの何気ない日常だったんですけども
あのー、すごい今が楽しいなって思いました
こんな恥ずかしいこと言いたくない。。。
はい、という訳ですね
えっと、プレゼントをね頂きました
で、あの
あ～言いたいことが一つあるよ！
あの2月14日生まれの皆さんは分かると思うんですけども
あのー、誕生日プレゼントがねこう
チョコにな、りがちなんですよ
ちょ、まぁいいですよ
ありがとうございます！
いいんですよ、ありがとうございます！
2回言っちゃったｗ
いいんですよ
誕生日プレゼントチョコレート、いいと思います
いいと思います
誕生日プレゼントチョコレートにするのはいいと思うんですけども
あうぅ～ん( ﾉД`)ｼｸｼｸ…
バレンタインデー、でもあるからさ
まぁ、それはチョコレート渡しておけば間違えないと思うんですけども、、、
いやいや、
ありがたいですよ
いや、本当にありがたいんですけども
まぁ、どっちかと言うとね、こうチョコを渡しとけばいいでしょうみたいな
ことに、なってしますんですよ
バレンタインデーが誕生日だと
その中で！
はい、なんと！
私が所属している事務所UUUMさんから誕生日プレゼントを頂きましたぁ～！
ありがとうございます！
絶対△％#〇ブラックサンダーだね
なんかね、ちょっとUUUMって書いてあるブラックサンダーが入ってる
つぶやきでぇ、見ちゃった。。。
あ、でもすごいなぁこれ
うわぁ、結構な量だな
はい、、、
おほっ。
すごい、ブラックサンダー,UUUMって書いてあります
それも、けっこう量ありますからね
あ、こんなたくさんありがとうございます
おぅ、中身は普通のブラックサンダーですね
美味い
これはまぁ、いいんですよ
バレンタッ
バレンタインデーですから
これ、多分ね他のクリエイターさん皆にも配られてて
まぁ、バレンタインはこれを送るっての感じになってんだと思いますよ
大事なのは
（指パッチン）
ここからだ
こっちでございますよ
全部開いてるんですけども、まだ僕中身見てませんよ
もう勢いで開けろってなったんですよ
もう開ける瞬間まできて
いや待てよ
UUUMだぞ？
待てよチョコレートはもう送られて来てる
もうチョコレートという選択肢はないわけですよ
その中で果たして
UUUMさんは
僕に、何をプレゼントしてくれるのかもう純粋に
ハードルが高いですよ？
純粋にハードルが高いのでちょっと
撮っています今
実はですねあの去年の誕生日とかね
サンダルにGODHAJIMEって書いてあるサンダルとかを送っていただいて
すごいセンスが良かったんですよ
ちょっと期待の意味も込めて
撮ってますよ
じゃあ開けますね
えぇ、怖いなんだろなんだろなんだろ
純粋に気になる
おっ
手紙
おうっとこれはぁ！
これはまだちょっと読めないぞ
手紙と、これ遊戯王カードではないな
手紙2枚と、ぅうん、何かが入ってました
手紙から失礼します
おうっ
はじめさんお誕生日おめ、あ
言わない方がいいですね
黙読！！
深いっ
ありがとございます
深い言葉が書いてありました
センキュー
失礼します
おうっ
ハッピーバースデー
こちらは？
お～おう
えーーっと
黙読！！
何？！
ちょと重要な語句具書いてあるぞ
あーなるほどなるほど
いやー本当いつもありがとうございます、ほんとに
なるほどなるほど
お～おう
ちょっと、フラグが大体の予想がついたんですけどまだ読めないぞ
ひとまずぅ
。。。
ちょっと遊戯王っぽいな
分かんない、なんなん分かんない分かんない分かんないですよ
分かんないですけど、遊戯王感が出てましたね
ざっと
開けさせていただきます
えぇ、開けますよ
開け！！
夢の扉
なになになに～！
えぇ、なになになに？！
うぇ、まだ見てないよ見てないよ何ですか？！
なになになに？！
なんか
袋に入ってるかな
取りますよじゃこれも
なになになに
ほいっ
あ、あ、あ、あ、あ、
これは
なんだ？
開けますよ？
見ていいですか？いきますよ？
せーのっ！
はいっ！
こっちだぁーー！
うわぁーーーー！！
えー待ってこれやばいやつじゃない？！
待った待った待った
これ多分やばいやつだよ
よーしゅ
かいわですね
そしてここにはブルーライトホワイトドラゴン
デゥエルモンスターズ
アッジアカンパ―セーションコンパニオン違う
アジアコンベーションエックスクリューシブ
待って待って！
これ多分やばいやつだ
値段調べてこよう
ちょっと値段調べてくる
なんか手が震えてきた
やばいなー
てかそもそも売っては、売ってもないぞこれ
いやー、あの
プレゼントって値段とかそういうのじゃないんですよ
ここなんですけど、、
。。。
気になるじゃないすか
あ、あったあったあった
お値段、、
うわぁーーー！！！
やべぇーー！！
うわうわうわうわうわうわ///
一般には売ってないんですけども
とあるサイトで見たところ
こちらのプレイマット
販売価格が
。。。
1万3千400円でございます
高けぇーーーーーー！！！
いや、極めて高いっすよ
えぇー本当にまじですかぁ！
いや、やばいよこれーちょっと開けれないな
ちょっとこれ記念として飾って置きます
僕さっきブルァデッキを作ってるんで
これは
正直
めちゃくちゃ嬉しい
えーすごいな
実はですねあの僕の今
マネージャーさんの方がですね遊戯王結構してまして
以外にそこらへんの話しも通る方でして
あの方ではなくちょっとこのセンスを出せなかった
誕生日プレゼントだと思います
本当にありがとうございます
うぅ～ん( ﾉД`)ｼｸｼｸ…
はい、というわけで！
すごいなー
というわけで24歳も
遊戯王も楽しみつつ
動画の方もまぁゆるーく雑に
ゔぁゔぁっとやってくんで
皆さんまたよろしくお願いします
アバンティーズ！